je suis enseignante et je crois dans
l'école pour moi un des rôles de l'école
c'est d'amener ces élèves là où ils
n'iraient pas tout seul je vais vous
parler des rencontres improbables
depuis 2002 je suis enseignante en
classe relais des classes relais accueil
des collégiens donc entre 11 et 16 ans
en décrochage scolaire le décrochage se
manifeste de plusieurs façons ça peut
être déscolarisation total allant
jusqu'à la phobie absentéisme
ça peut être aussi des élèves qui ont
des comportements à civilité provocation
c'est d'ailleurs les reportages qu'on
voit souvent quand il ya des reportages
sur les cases relais aux journaux
télévisés mais ça peut être aussi des
élèves qui sont présents physiquement et
dans une très grande passivité et qui
sont donc des décrocheurs silencieux
donc je travaille avec des élèves qui
sont en difficulté dans ce qu'ils soient
en difficulté à l'école mais qui met
aussi l'institution en difficulté un
accompagnement en classe relais peut
durer deux mois trois mois six mois mais
ça n'excède jamais une année scolaire
pour ne pas que ce soit un palier
d'orientation
donc chaque mois il ya des entrées et
des sorties permanentes
il ya 300 classes relais en france si on
presse il ya deux classes relais et nous
nous avons fait le choix de fonctionner
en temps partagé
c'est à dire l'élève à son collège il
reste dans sa classe de collège et vient
deux ou trois demi journées sur le
dispositif relais on a fait ce choix de
fonctionnement qui est un peu
particulier comme ça il n'y a pas de
rupture avec la classe ordinaire
donc c'est important pour les
adolescents d'être comme les autres et
en plus ça nous permet de fonctionner
des tout petits groupes
trois quatre cinq élèves donc dans une
semaine je peux voir douze jeunes et sur
une année entre 20 et 25
un accompagnement en classe relais ça
démarre par un premier entretien
même si ça arrive il est accompagné avec
sa mère lors du premier entretien je
demande toujours à l'élève de décliner
un petit peu son parcours scolaire qui
me parle de comment ça s'est passé
alors je vous demande ton école
maternelle c'était où il me dit pas de
souci parce que tu as des souvenirs
petite section moyenne section
des bons des mauvais souvenirs il me dit
j'étais nul on passe à l'école primaire
en décline des classes cp ce1 et là rien
ne vient pas j'étais nul
actuellement il était scolarisé
scolarisé en 4e
on arrive au collège et là tout de suite
il me dit encore plus nuls
les élèves de classes relais ont tous
des histoires singulières mais à quelque
chose qui est récurrent
j'ai tous ces jeunes c'est qu'ils n'ont
ils n'ont pas ils ont une image très
dégradée de même ils se sont pas
capables de construire
et finalement quand on n'est pas capable
de construire et ben autant fuir se
replier sur soi même ou bien refuser que
faire comment faire bon si je reproduis
les mêmes choses que dans les classes
ordinaires bassa général les mêmes
effets et sa ancrera en plus ces
difficultés bon je suis enseignante
j'ai donc les mêmes objectifs que mes
collègues et j'ai aussi les mêmes
exigences à savoir l'acquisition du
socle commun le projet que je vais vous
présenter ce soir que j'ai mis en place
dès ma deuxième année de classe relais
c'est le croisement entre eux de
réflexion et trois constats premières
réflexions la priorité et b c'est
justement de redonner une image positive
à ces jeunes de façon à ce que il en
aller vers des nouveaux apprentissages
qu'ils prennent plaisir à apprendre donc
vraiment leur redonner confiance en eux
deuxième réflexion ça c'est une
conviction il est important de proposer
aux élèves des tâches complexes à ne pas
confondre avec compliqué même si on est
en difficulté à trop simplifier le
travail ça maintient l'élève dans le
faire la réalisation au détriment de la
réflexion et du coup ça les rend
dépendants de l'expert de celui qui sait
et donc ça les encres encore plus dans
une forme de passivité d'attentisme donc
le choix pédagogiques que j'ai fait
c'est de proposer des élèves aux tâches
des tâches complexes et ancré dans le
réel faire pour de vrai en
fonctionnement en mode projet
et les trois constats donc qui m'ont
amené à proposer le projet premier
constat dans la société les publics
personnes âgées et adolescents ne se
rencontrent pas ou quasiment pas de
façon spontanée il n'y a pas d'endroit
et on sait que la méconnaissance génère
des clichés le rejet donc premier
constan deuxième constat on est en 2003
on dit que les adolescents ils savent
utiliser l'internet il sonné avec hors
certes ils ont des habiletés mais ils
font toujours les mêmes choses et
troisième constat les personnes âgées ne
connaissent pas internet ou peu or si on
les associe pas ce mode de communication
est à cette culture numérique
ils seront encore plus mis à l'écart de
la société
moi je me souviens ma mère qui regardait
son journal ouest france et qui était
très agacé de voir ces trois w qui me
demandait toujours mais c'est quoi ces
trois w
donc le croisement de ces deux
réflexions de ces trois constats ont
amené à proposer le projet
intergénérations l'intergénération c'est
la rencontre entre les collégiens de
classes relais et des personnes âgées
qui sont en résidence autour d'internet
les élèves après une formation à
l'utilisation réfléchi raisonné et
construite d'internet
et puis une sensibilisation à la posture
de formateurs se rendre de deux fois par
semaine donc dans la résidence pour
animer des ateliers afin de faire
découvrir internet d'expliquer de
montrer donc aux résidents on a mis en
place les premiers ateliers en 2003
alors vous dites vous bien qu est ce que
je faisais avec 1,7 en 2003 nous on a
mis dans la maison de retraite les
projets teulier en 2003 lors du premier
atelier la rencontre pourtant improbable
à entre les personnes âgées
la rencontre a eu lieu les élèves ont
pris leur rôle de formateur très au
sérieux
on leur avait confié une mission mission
faire pour de vrai donc on le
reconnaissait un savoir et les personnes
âgées base était ravi d'être
intéressante pour les adolescents en
plus elle viser autre chose que ce
qu'elle faisait habituellement à la
résidence
elles se sont eux aussi capables d'aller
vers la nouveauté ce qui est quand même
rassurant
et puis elle se rendit compte qu'elle
avait encore un rôle dans l'éducation de
ces adolescents la kim est quand même
une institution en difficulté donc le
projet après on va continuer le contenu
des ateliers à évoluer en fonction de
l'évolution de la technique mais le
fonctionnement est toujours resté un
petit peu pareil à savoir les élèves
avant d'aller à l'atelier ils préparent
des activités
il est est il fondé supports de
formation alors c'est intéressant parce
qu'ils se mettent à la place des
personnes âgées il change de point de
vue et quand on change le point de vue
c'est quand même le début de l'ouverture
en arrivant à l'atelier qui peut
accueillir entre cinq et quinze
personnes âgées les trois quatre cinq
collégiens serre la main à toutes les
personnes présentes
et puis à des personnes âgées sont déjà
souvent installés devant les ordinateurs
et a donc là c'est parti pour une heure
les élèves prennent en main l'atelier
j'avais oublié de vous dire quand même
on est en 2003 quand j'avais proposé
l'atelier intergénérations il y avait
des partenaires qui avait dit tout de
suite ok notamment un directeur de
résidence il a dit moi je veux bien que
ça se passe dans ma résidence une
association de brest a fini avait
proposé de m'aider à informer les
adolescents
et puis la ville de brest avait installé
dans la salle dans la résidence une
salle uniquement pour les ateliers avec
des ordinateurs
cette salle d'ailleurs a été ouverte
après au public et est devenu un papier
un point d'accès public à internet
donc là on est à l'atelier donc vous
visualisez donc c'est parti pour une
heure steven aujourd'hui il a importé
son rapport de stage il avait parlé avec
jean desse de son stage que la leaf en
plomberie parce que gens quand ils t'ont
activités il travaille dans le bâtiment
deux jours avant steven avait rendu son
rapport de stage avait dit mon
étonnement quand j'avais vu qu'il avait
rédigé son rapport de stage en police en
taille 36 et il me dit ben oui ma gens y
voient pas bien alors il avait fait ce
choix
marie louise est déjà installé marie
luce est en fauteuil roulant est déjà
installée elle est difficilement la tête
pour regarder l'écran elle a l'habitude
de travailler avec roanne froide
s'installe à côté d'elle et puis
aujourd'hui elle a décidé de répondre à
sa cousine donc elle dicte son courrier
électronique
roanne et au clavier elle regarde quand
même à l'écran parce que roanne et
l'orthographe c'est pas toujours lé
pelle éventuellement les mots et roanne
avait précautionneusement agrandi les
caractères prenez un élève qui a un
parcours scolaire assez agitée émaillé
de plusieurs conseils de discipline
problèmes de comportement et à la fin de
son temps aux dispositifs relais dernier
atelier il me dit j'aimerais bien partir
plus tôt puisque j'ai envie de passer
chez la fleuriste pour acheter une rose
parce que j'ai envie de l'offrir
marie-louise en fin d'atelier
on entend les personnes âgées qui
remercie les collégiens j'entends gaëtan
dire finalement on oublie qu'ils sont
vieux on leur parle comme à des potes
enfin avait avec le respect quand même
les élèves utilisent des méthodes
actives pour animer les ateliers et
notamment y met les personnes âgées en
situation de production
c'est pas tous deux utilisent internet
comme comme des consommateurs c'est
mieux d'être acteur donc on a proposé
des activités de co écriture et
notamment un blog on avait ouvert un
blog longages qui étaient bilingues
français normalisé langage sms
cette élection c'était assez cocasse
parce que les personnes âgées étaient
ravis d'apprendre le langage sms comme
ça ne pouvait pas tes leurs
petits-enfants leurs arrières petits
enfants elle et les collégiens mari
pouvait profiter d un des compétences
des personnes âgées on était bien sûr un
échange de compétences la résidence
accueille aussi des retraités qui
viennent fleurs différentes activités
et puis on a vu ces retraités se
rapprocher du papier du point d'accès
public à internet donc de notre salle
notre porte est toujours ouverte
ils sont entrés ils sont restés et ils
sont revenus
du coup on se retrouve avec trois
générations les très âgés jusqu'à 95 96
ans les retraités et les collégiens là
le contenu des ateliers aussi
enrichi parce que il y avait demandé tu
es plus précise l'arrivée des réseaux
sociaux les élèves ont formé les
personnes âgées utiliser facebook skype
enfin et c est parfois l'élève était
amené à faire une présentation à tout le
groupe et il était obligé de demandes
milteau manette est obligé de demander
un petit peu le silence parce que ben ça
bardait quoi et où
quand je croisais le regard de l'élève
je voyais bien qu'ils prenaient la
mesure de la posture pas toujours facile
du formateur ou ou de l'enseignant on
s'est rendu compte que les personnes
âgées montée en compétences donc on a
voulu faire de la validation des acquis
les collégiens ont créé des brevets et
là les personnes âgées étaient tout à
fait dans la posture d'un prenant pas ce
qui se pressait avant de passer le
brevet et puis il était drôlement ému le
jour où il recevait le brevet parce
qu'ils avaient les félicitations du
formateur en 2012 les tablettes sont
arrivés et on sait on a vite vu que la
prise en main des tablettes était
compliquée pour les personnes âgées
donc on a imaginé faire un écran
d'accueil simplifiée avec des icônes
plus grande des raccourcis plus évident
donc toujours avec les élèves un quand
je dis on c'est toujours avec les élèves
et a du coup on s'est rapprochés
d'étudiants ingénieurs de télécom
bretagne nouvelle rencontre improbable
parce que les étudiants ingénieurs c'est
les élèves pour qui l'école ça a été une
réussite
les collégiens ou c'est un peu compliqué
donc ils se croisent pas trop donc on
s'est rapproché des étudiants ingénieurs
on a très bien collaboré on a mis en
place une application qui s'appelle papy
launcher et à la fin je voyais bien les
les élèves me dira finalement ils sont
sympas et se trouvait même des centres
d'intérêts communs
puis on a continué de collaboration on a
fait l'acquisition d'un robot humanoïde
en 2014 now est là que faire avec now
tâche complexe toujours avec les élèves
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
s'il était évident que nao allait venir
aux ateliers intergénérations donc là on
s'est rapproché de nouveaux étudiants
lassé des designers qui sont venus avec
nous à des ateliers pour voir comment
now peuvent venir en aide aux personnes
en perte
nomi la première sortie de now à
l'atelier intergénérations ça a été un
grand moment
la rencontre entre na ho et les
personnes âgées un grand moment
d'émotion nouvelles rencontres
improbables et naos devenait un vecteur
de lien social
donc on a créé des scénarios pour
utiliser now et pour la mise en place
des applications on a fait appel à nos
étudiants ingénieurs avec qui on avait
déjà eu des contacts
toutes ces rencontres improbables là
elles ont contribué à ce que ces élèves
retrouvent confiance en eux du coup ils
se sont réinvestis dans des travaux
proposés on retrouve l envie et même le
goût d'apprendre et ils ont modifié leur
rapport au savoir
donc ils ont raccroché les jours pour
bien s'occuper de nous
on ne se sent pas intégrer
et ça ça nous fait décrocher et même
parfois déraper
et quand on se sent été
ça nous aide à avancer et à vieux coup
ça les aide
iran n'étant plus respectueux
aussi plus
besoin que l'on
fasse confiance très heureux
à la résidence pour s'exprime tisser
[Musique]
salut
restée calme et si on est on des
elle argumente avec des mots
il
moins d'élèves par classe en plus
chacun à prendre
dans la bienvenue
avec
non
retrouver notre confiance et avoir envie
d'étudier
[Musique]
et pour qu'on est tous un métier plus
être fier de ce qu'ont fait cuisinier
plombier ou
bah
et apprendre à chacun son rythme ça te
fait pour aller de l'avant
personne du corps
ça y est
dans ce poids ici
et tout y fait
[Musique]
pour voir grandir sans
il grandit
/
et commun
être aidé
étudiants
[Musique]
ils sont
comme si
[Musique]
viens
ce
[Musique]
les élèves en tous temps à dire l on
tend à nous apprendre
prenons le temps de lire
considérons les comme valable
ils savent ce qui les met en échec
et faisons ensemble un collège pour le
bien-être de tous et de toutes
mélanger les générations créé des
opportunités de rencontres improbables
faire confiance aider les personnes à
retrouver confiance en elle ça génère
une dynamique pour pouvoir faire créer
ensemble et donc mieux vivre ensemble
parce que pour mieux vivre ensemble il
faut faire ensemble
au fait au début j'ai dit je suis
enseignante je rectifie j'étais
enseignante jusqu'au 1er septembre
maintenant c'est à vous je vous fais
confiance de là où vous êtes avec vos
moyens avec vos moyens
imaginez comment créer des rencontres
improbables et surtout oser et aux ans
[Applaudissements]